the left has been completely unopposed i
think it was jessie kelly
maybe it was just a kelly somebody said
that the left won the culture war
because they're the only ones fighting
it
there's truth in that and like michael
malus says i know he gets a shout out
every other episode here but the
difference between the left and the
right is the left is serious
yep that's it you got a bunch of zealots
who will do anything they say by any
means necessary yeah violent psychopaths
burning down buildings smashing things
and
you get the republican party like don't
you do that yeah
yeah one thing i was mentioning the
other day is that nancy pelosi comes out
and screams january 6th and what do the
republicans come back and say
january 6th instead of coming out and
saying antifa
that's they they don't do it you guys
endorsed this times
20 all summer long more than times 20.
um people were rioting and literally
burning down this country for months
straight and we were told that that was
mostly peaceful and it was a-okay
the republican party is uh a
is subservient to the democratic party
period hands down 100 percent all of
them
every single one even with a few
exceptions oh you really know
you're going to rand paul paul made the
brianna taylor bill
yeah rand paul entered the fray under
their terms
now i respect the guy yeah but also too
that's rand paul coming at it not from
a republican perspective but a
libertarian perspective and being in
favor of police reform i don't think he
did that
why is there no david dorn dornbill
why why is there no one standing up and
demanding a national holiday or making
us think about it
and i know you mentioned the media but
that's that's not relevant when even
rand paul comes out and says
you're framing your rules here's my
proposition they are subservient to the
democrats
period yeah i was saying that the media
tempers the the flame it basically heats
up the metal
to get the iron hot so that you can as a
politician strike it and be like i want
to make a bill about this topic because
this
the media has made it such a hot ready
to be molded
topic and that david dorn thing there
wasn't enough public knowledge about the
guy
trump had the opportunity to do so much
he never did i know
even though trump was a fighter he still
would give the interviews to these
organizations acting as though they were
neutral arbiters of anything they
weren't
they're they're it's all for the
political agenda so
even during all of this you can force
the press to cover stories
okay and and republicans never do
they always bow down to the narrative
from the left
so that's it is it just because they
don't have the contacts in the
in the media organizations or the the
organization because they're not serious
because they're just old they're not not
all of them are old collecting a
paycheck
you're right not all this is not serious
look i mean
you get um marjorie taylor green and she
pushes back much in the way that um
many of the democrats do like the squad
especially
and they hate her for it there you go
you got a fighter there
lauren bobert pushes back still though
almo
i would say maybe marjorie taylor green
is the only one who's not playing into
their narrative and is actually pushing
back and saying you know i counter this
but almost all the republicans just say
whatever it is the democrats narrative
is they argue on their terms
there you go the uniparty i think no
no it's it's the the neocons joined the
democrats a long time ago yeah
yeah bill crystal basically it was
during obama's
reign uh that they went over and got on
his drone bomb
and and the remaining republicans are
just like
oh you know there's no leaders there's
no leadership not
not in our government not really no the
democrats have leaders tons of them
maybe they
they do yeah absolutely how do you
define a leader uh
they say they they they take action they
command they demand it's like
they go follow aoc yeah aoc can i also
come out and say whatever she wants and
it becomes major news right she becomes
the story
right ted cruz goes on vacation and then
runs back cowering like
i'm so sorry i was just flying my
daughter i'm so sorry
i don't think regarding what we were
talking about earlier about is there a
way
like how do i is there a way out of this
i think that
i don't see it that people could refocus
the problem onto
the the banking industry and realize
that they're printing us into madness
i mean maybe maybe the amc gamestop
stuff stuff like that
institutional use using legal channels
to cause problems for major institutions
you know and it's it's not illegal to do
it
it's like people just liked the stock
and so it happened
but i i look at a lot of the strategies
and the tactics and the and the
temperament of people on the right
and it's like look at january 6th
you know you get a lot of people who are
100 adamant it was the right thing and
they're defending it
after it happened they were like they
were defending it and saying a bunch of
stuff about it
and you get a bunch of people on the
right saying it was wrong clearly it was
wrong because
the right doesn't have the same um
they don't they don't have the same
ability to engage in that kind of tactic
the left does
the left gets away with it because they
control cultural institutions
so in the event that these people still
did something there's
first of all they shouldn't have there's
a bunch of things that should have a
bunch of other things that should have
been done
in response to it the left plays the
same game
when antifa burns down a building
democrats
don't say anything they never talk about
it ever
they fundraise to bail them out and they
shut up
what happens with january 6 the
republicans all say oh it was bad oh
we're so sorry
and then you get some republicans who
are clearly democrats saying like my
colleagues won't even say the right
thing
and then even the ones who are saying
it's political and to ignore it are
still bringing it up and making it the
center focus interesting
yeah so they're walking right and it's
like they're
they're playing they're fighting an
alligator underwater man i know
it's uh i think maybe not talking but
talking about politics one thing but
like trying to
trying to fix the system by using that
is fighting the alligator underwater
like trying to use the political
establishment
to fix the political establishment is
just not the place to do it
there's no attack there's no tact
there's no strategy no
we need it it's random self-centered and
there's no leadership in the in the
government no no
in the in the anti-establishment faction
yeah i don't
i don't like cult worship in general i
don't think a a a guy or a girl can like
come out and be like i can do it like
you elon musk kind of but then
you know his whole bitcoin debacle
screwed a bunch of people he's out for
himself
right and you can only ever be out for
yourself first and you should be out for
yourself first the left is out for a
collective victory
and everyone else are out for themselves
they're all out for themselves too they
do it in the guise of a collective no no
but it all serves the collective
i guess as long as their cult ideology
expands
they benefit from it on the right though
there's conflict between even people who
are anti-establishment
yeah absolutely yeah and there should be
the left does eat them
you fire you know fire firing each other
as well the circular firing squad for
sure
i think there should be conflict between
we should all have healthy conflict
at you know you never want to subserve
to another human
really i don't think even in a marriage
you know you want there to be healthy
conflict and communication
not neces confrontation at the very
least if not conflict but
so we need a system that allows for that
obviously i don't think a human is going
to come and be like i will follow me
everyone like the captain america
but we'll build a system i think that
will help facilitate a solution
that's my goal anyway here's the thing i
think it's important to have leaders but
at the same time part of why the left is
winning is because really being
committed to their principles doesn't
require a lot of
like look at what they're doing and
they're being violent and psychopathic
that doesn't exactly require a high
degree of virtue or thought
i mean what the right is talking about
and what the right needs to really do to
get people on board and have any kind of
victory
is encourage people to live their lives
in strong and virtuous ways and
oppose immorality everywhere they see it
that's difficult that's a lot
harder to get people to do than to throw
molotov cocktails at buildings or
scream down people who disagree with you
politically
and it's it's it's also vague like how
do you tell someone how to live morally
like that's a challenging
like jordan peterson does eight hour you
know
lectures just just about that about one
way that you can
but you have more just 100 but i'd also
say and this is part of what being
conservative is is recognizing the
age-old wisdom just saying like these
are the virtues people need to live
these out as best they
can that's what we have to encourage our
followers to do i've said this before
but conservatism has very much become
this very
loose affiliation of people who have
kind of vaguely similar ideas about the
economy
and oftentimes it falls back on this
philosophy of just like leave me alone
and let me do whatever i want but which
is actually more classically liberal
exactly exactly we need something much
more robust and this is why i've always
said we need something much more robust
i've said more recently more robust and
rooted in catholicism and
what i'm saying there too is something
really really well rooted in
virtues and people living their lives
in an upright fashion and i don't think
that's too vague if you're referencing
the virtues specifically
like the reason i refer to it as vague
is because when you're like
antifa is like we're gonna throw a brick
you know that's like a call to action
like pick this up and do it and then
it's done but like if you're like
live humbly be humble like that's a
vague command
you know so how do you implement the
virtues that's fair
well and i think too a lot of what they
talk about is
tearing the system down and they
deconstruct everything philosophically
they don't necessarily have to put
anything forward in terms of what should
replace the system once it's been
removed
so they're not in the business of
building things whereas we're supposed
to be
so again that's an edge that they have
they're destroying things
exactly and that's the point that's
their goal
i guess a good way to exude virtue is to
make internet video and show
people like make cartoons do it yours
become it yourself and then allow people
to
to witness interesting yeah mockery is
is good
but it seems to be i guess uh not as
effective it's been 10 years
the the you who'd have thought that when
you saw you know gamergate
that these cultists would have reached
the highest levels of government
the presidential office i never would
have and and it happened six years it
really is so weird
but i didn't know that honestly it
doesn't surprise me at all
so the so the the so the the right or
the anti-establishment whatever you want
to call it
has lost every step of the way
politically absolutely yeah
some victories here and there some you
know some some victories in certain
areas
but uh trump was only holding back the
the title floods you know
actually tim what happened was we won so
much we got tired of winning
so we decided to start losing all the
time
with someone that can't lose yeah donald
trump won
and a lot of people felt that was it and
the good example of that is 2018.
people voted for trump because they
don't care for the republicans of the
democrats many of these people
trump wins but he won like but with only
88 000 votes across three states which
gave him a good electoral college
victory
come 2018. those people didn't come out
and vote
so the data suggests that the people
said i voted for trump i'm done
that was it and then the democrats got
the house back and they used it to
burn everything to the ground 100
percent and and
this is very easily evidenced by the the
victories of the republicans in 2020
so uh the polls were all off it was
funny looking at the new york times
where it was like these are lean blue
and they were solid red and these were
solid blue and some of them flipped red
like even an urban center in florida
turned red
because what happened was you had a
bunch of democrats say
we're not going to culture war you vote
for us we're going to get you health
care
yes and everyone said thank you the
first thing
these scumbags did exactly vote for
impeachment
nancy pelosi came over and they dropped
their knees and they licked her feet
and then they went and voted for
whatever she told them to vote for
and then many of them lost the
re-election because people were like i
don't care
for you you did not get us what we
wanted
but still it shows you that these
democrats
promise all these things then deliver
nothing well and this is part of
why i think again even though i will not
make hard and fast predictions here
there
is there is some hope for a backlash
because
i think when people vote democrats it's
most often because they believe they
will provide them
things like inexpensive health care or
worker benefits they'll strengthen the
unions now i'm not saying that democrats
actually deliver on these things or that
the strategy democrats would
take for improving people's quality of
life are in any way
effective but is what people seem to
want from democrats
i don't think people really want the
woke ideology and so when they see the
democrats
bending the knee to these organizations
like black lives matter and antifun
going off the deep end with all the woke
stuff they're more likely to say well
you guys
aren't doing the things that we actually
elected you to do you're just pandering
to the far left so
we're going to vote for republicans now
i don't i don't know if actually solves
anything when republicans don't actually
fight no no there's there's truth in
that too
there's there's a lot of truth in that
so then it's just a gradual decay
yeah it's just a slow collapse well
that's that's what happens to societies
nothing lasts forever i'm not saying
it's it's a good thing or that we should
just roll over and accept it again i
think everyone should do their part but
i believe doing your part has a whole
lot more to do with living a good life
as an individual
than actually trying to change the
system but they're taking the system
over and using it to
arrest and detain people yeah 100
so if you just sit back and do your
thing how long until they come to your
house and they arrest you
they come to your house and arrest you
either way if it gets that bad the point
is you just have to be the best possible
person you can become
and if that happens and if enough of the
population actually cultivates virtue
then they could prevent that kind of a
disaster people could actually rise up
but i know that people not working on
themselves and not trying to become
better human beings only ends in
disaster for everybody
this last month i've been so focused on
being a better person and listening
and it's it's amazing how fast you can
change
if you really i mean you got to have
self-awareness but
yeah i mean we we all have things we
need to work on i definitely have a lot
i want to work on but when you think
about the fact that it really only takes
30 days to build a new habit i mean
that's incredible
anyone can change their life there could
be something that you've been doing
every day for 20 years and you just take
a month to do the opposite it's really
difficult but you'll end up building a
completely new habit it's amazing
sound like jordan peterson it's like man
it's like you you can build new habits
all you have to do is get your life in
order
i mean that's something clean clean your
room that's something my parents would
tell me as a kid yeah it takes 30 30
days to build a habit and i'd be like
whatever you know as a kid you're like
30 days that's so much time
now it's like man a month just flies by
and i could be a significantly improved
person by the end of a month if i decide
at the beginning of the month that
that's what i want for myself
i think most months i like most other
people don't make that decision and i
should
so like if you're changing a habit you
just when you notice yourself
doing it you acknowledge that you're
doing it
uh what do you mean by that like in
terms of how you cultivate it yeah i
think
so so give me an example of something a
person might want to change
oh like uh i don't know
drinking coffee in the morning yeah so
something they would want to stop doing
yeah you can't just i think you're
drinking coffee yeah so so here's the
thing
i think usually they say the best way of
stopping yourself from doing something
is replace it with something else
so for 30 days you would just say drink
tea every morning instead of coffee
and then by the end of that month he
would be higher addicted to tea
yeah exactly this has more caffeine it
can have more caffeine but it doesn't
have to be tea it can be something else
you can just be like i have water every
morning it can be something that doesn't
even seem to have that much of an effect
but knowing that you have replaced one
thing with another thing actually builds
the habit of doing the second thing
you know you know you do it's easy it's
like when you when you're pouring your
coffee just pour
one ounce less every single day just a
tiny bit
for one week you pour one ounce less and
then next week you do it one ounce less
and then eventually you're having like a
small you know shot
that takes a lot of discipline too
though because what's to stop you at one
point for me like you know what today's
my cheat day and i'm just going to pour
things yeah but i think a lot of people
do a cheat day and then it just becomes
a whole thing
yep they just fall back i hear it a lot
from people like i'm doing keto i can't
eat a bowl of macaroni and cheese but
i'll make an exception for the bowl with
macaroni and cheese
okay you're not dating yeah exactly
exactly exactly it works yeah
yeah i i i think um some things you can
just go cold turkey
you know it depends on what your
schedule's like if you've got a heavy
workload
getting a coffee is hard getting off you
know smoking stopping smoking cigarettes
those are difficult things because
the addictions and the physiological
dependence but uh some things are like
working out make you feel better
big time yeah so uh go for a walk in the
morning you can actually take up smoking
too
you know what i don't want to i wanted
to start i was like i feel like i like
myself more as a person no i i used to
i used to smoke a bait i know it reminds
me of you know old noir film you know
what i mean so it's like
now i feel like i just want to wear a
trench coat with the collar pop and just
say like
things about the city that i live in and
how horrible it is have you guys ever
smoked no one sees the underbelly of
this place
um salvia have you guys ever smoked
salvia no are you familiar i've not
smoked i don't advocate you have it it's
an advocate
it's a type of sage they call it salvia
isn't that like salvia means sage
isn't that bad well yeah yeah is that
what people were doing and they would
get like crazy high for like 60 seconds
and lose their minds and like
yeah it's so weird but what they would
do is they'd go into a
into like a smoked a steam tent and then
they put a bunch of it in like
what in heat and then it would vaporize
it and then what does it leave them in
the vapor
oh smoking pick up a new habit no no no
no no don't please don't do this stuff
this stuff makes people go crazy you can
pick up like a crack habit in less than
30.
that's the thing no none of that so how
do you build a new habit of something
you want to
learn how to do like um oh i don't know
listen
increase your listening skills yeah i
mean again i
i think i'm no like expert or self-help
guru here but i would just say that you
have to start by just doing that thing
every day for 30 days and you have to
schedule it at a specific time so that
it works
its way into your schedule and then
eventually it just becomes a normal
thing to you that doesn't require as
much effort to get started with
and that's when it becomes a habit yeah
for me you know when i started making
videos every day at a certain time
yeah it was like it was like a personal
obligation yes like i would i would
feel a kind of anguish if i didn't do
what i was supposed to do
you know i decided like i got to do this
thing at that time and now like every
day at 4pm i have to have a video out
and so like like the nightmares that
i've had few and far between is like
i'll have a nightmare where it's like
i'm looking at my phone and i'm like oh
no i didn't schedule
my video properly and i'm like i've
cause it's i'm breaking
i'm breaking a promise to myself that's
awesome and so i'm like
there's you know it's a promise to
myself and to a lot of people who
who watch and believe in the content
it's like i i can't i have to do it has
to get done no matter what no excuses
100 yeah i mean we we do a video every
single thursday
um for a time we went and for animation
that's pretty uncommon
we went i think like two and a half
years without missing a single
upload at one point it's it's very rare
that we missed one but it that's what it
was it was just an obligation to myself
saying like i have to get this done and
the way it started was
i took some time away from uploading and
just tried to work on a bunch of videos
at once
and i was still in college at the time
and so i was
in school while i was trying to keep up
with this once
a week schedule and i was keeping up
with it and then eventually at some
point
i just like ran out of extra videos and
then i had to actually create a new
video from scratch each week
and when the team was smaller at one
point it was basically just me
doing doing basically everything that
entire week
but i would just force myself to because
i couldn't let myself not upload that
week and
and now i have this really consistent
schedule sometimes we do twice a week
we're trying to get
twice a week done more often there are
periods of time where we'll do two
weeks you've been doing it long enough
now so where you know a lot of people
don't know this but uh
james doesn't actually do any of the
voices anymore it's all it's all korean
voice actors
korean animators korean animators it's
actually tim tim does all of it
i'm the korean one yeah i just worked 30
hours a day every day
every day for me exactly thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you